i put on the refrigerator wednesday
virtual burning man
and it's 24 hours and i i yeah 24 hours
24 hours i'd like you to go in one room
in the house and not make any noise
i have spent money on a ticket that
ticket gives me a login the login gets
me into the zoom meeting
she's in school school doesn't matter
okay what is she even learning what
class is she learning she's wearing
fractions
fractions i'm a whole person
you're a whole person i am an eternal
being from the realm of power and light
honey do you know who terence mckenna is
you're not using the computer it's her
computer for school please for the love
of god
hand over the laptop so i can begin my
journey you know what we're done here
just lock yourself in a room for 24
hours that's all i'm asking
you are sick you're out of your mind
you're a bad father oh come on
oh stop this is ridiculous
that's insane leave the laptop please no
you are a drug addict and i can't
believe i
married you like come on in front of the
kids like that
this is insane in front of the children
really
bye oh i'll see you when you get back
hi is this jessica's class okay
jessica's gonna see everybody tomorrow
i'm going on an
ancient journey